all right Steve's with us Steve is in
New York hey Steve welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up so my wife and I are
working on the baby stuff so I want to
call me baby step number two and my
wife's about 80% of the way there so I
got her two relatively easily to allow
me to start my contributions to my role
for 57 is doing 10% and I also have the
option where I can contribute additional
money to my attention both pre-tax and
post tax currently I'm doing about $800
and I'd say about 3/4 of that is post
tax and I'm having a hard time getting
her to agree to let me stop that so we
can really knock out the baby steps and
get moving I don't know what to do right
now but you all have discussed that the
fastest way to become wealthy just you
know that and the reason that she is
pushing back is because the money that
get that extra money that's going into
attention is it's a guaranteed eight and
a quarter percent return and she's just
having a credit card as if inerrant and
18 percent Interest I I know I'm a
hundred percent in and she's almost
there yeah well let me just tell you
that the OS this is a temporary decision
you can do whatever you want to do
obviously so you can do your plan if you
under your plans but you're calling me
about how to do our plan and so on
answer it that way so obviously you can
do whatever you want I mean that's not
you guys are allowed to do whatever you
want to do but in terms of the thing is
if I hire a personal trainer and he has
a six-pack and I have a keg if I don't
want to listen to him that doesn't make
sense even if what he's saying to me
feels weird I want to understand why
he's saying to me what he's saying to me
but if he says do this type of exercise
do this type of nutrition
if I want to look like him he looks like
a Greek god and I have a big huge belly
which I do then I need to do what he
says to do because he has the proof my
theory has gotten me a big belly right
right and that's what we're dealing with
here so now so the point is you know
your plan her plan your best thinking
her best thinking has gotten you to
where you are you're trying to do a new
way of thinking to get a different
result that's all positive all that's
good so you need to embrace that and as
a friend of mine says submit yourself to
a different process to get a different
result submission for me is really hard
submission for most people is really
hard submission for your wife to a
process is really hard she's struggling
with that and that's that's a human
thing that's okay it doesn't make her a
bad person but um it's a human thing so
anyway the the answer as to why we teach
you to do this might be important in
this discussion so you can try
discussing it this way I guess why we
teach you to stop all investing even
though it's not mathematically correct
is simply this what you focus on does
what you win at and this is a temporary
thing
you're not going to stop investing for
very long it's not going to take you
very long to get through this in the
scope of your life this is 1 2 or 3
years this is not 30 years it's not 10
years it's not even five years it's for
a very short period of time so this
truly is a hypothetical theoretical
discussion the math really doesn't
change much in two years on this so stop
it for two years because what you focus
on is what you win at no one wins on
something without focusing on it and
sometimes focusing exclusively on it
when you guys got married how long ago
was that it was 2003
so you've been married 17 years yeah
okay the reason you got married is
because you focused on her to the
exclusion of all other girls and for
that matter all of the things you
couldn't think about anything else right
then but her she couldn't think about
anything else but you and you ended up
getting married because you focused on
it
you were completely absorbed with it you
completely bought in you drank the
kool-aid you see what I'm saying and so
what you focus on is what you went out
the reason you got married
no one hardly unless it's a toxic
relationship gets married because
someone didn't care you know you're like
I'm freaking all in here right and
that's how you win so that's my argument
for this and that's why our stuff has
worked and actually the disgust with
missing out on the return the guaranteed
eight and a half percent return to
disgust with that will drive you even
harder to get on out of debt so I do
recommend turning off all investing
temporarily because what you focus on
you win and this is more about behavior
and focus than it is math it will it is
the shortest path to wealth for you even
though that feels oxymoronic it is the
shortest path to wealth
that's the deal